hey guys it's Tuesday so very 23rd I'm
Mary and you're watching gamespot news
you can no longer download the ill-fated
silent Hills predecessor PT but thanks
to fallout 4s crafting system you can at
least visit that dreaded hallway a
fallout 4 workshop architect has
recreated the hallway from PT youtuber
kita posted the reimagining and it's
enough to bring back horrible memories
of weird fetus things and terrifying
ghost ladies go for it Keita recreated
the horror game with the workshop
feature and fallout 4s crafting system
it's got everything from that bathroom
to the front for a where you eventually
meet Lisa there's even a spooky radio
broadcast that haunts PT sound waves no
Norman Reedus though a girl can dream
star wars battlefront got a big honkin
update today but that's not everybody's
talking about everybody's talking about
the outer rim expansion image it comes
with more maps weapons heroes and in all
new mode quote unquote we say all new
mode because we don't know what it is
the content will take you to places like
factories on Sullust and Jabba the
Hutt's palace on Tatooine no further
details about the new mode were divulged
we also don't know any specific release
date they didn't even tell us if job
himself would make an appearance in
addition EA reiterated today in a blog
post that all battlefront players can
expect new updates in March whether they
buy outer rim or not at least three
further expansions are gonna follow best
bin summer 2016 Death Star fall 2016 in
the most exciting untitled early 2017
they got at least a whole year to figure
out that title finally all the games you
get for free in March with an xbox gold
account or announced today thank God for
Xbox espana their video shows all the
games you can get with xbox gold on Xbox
one you get Sherlock Holmes crimes and
punishment and Lords of the Fallen xbox
360 free games will be supreme commander
2 and the first Borderlands in the
meantime you can still pick up
february's free games that's hand of
fate and
Styx master of shadows on xbox one as
well as gears of war two on xbox 360
while I'm at it and PlayStation 3 D news
they did conclude the vote to play
initiative where Plus subscribers could
vote on one of the three games they
wanted in March to be free and broforce
one you don't believe me it was
confirmed on Twitter look it up broforce
will be free once marches instant game
collection lineup becomes available on
march first and that's it for me today
but I'll see you guys again at five
thirty that's when we're doing a rocket
League Championship live right here so
we'll see you back then
you